- I wanna close up the
show with one more story
to make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(lively music)
(audience applauding)
Ernest Hemingway is
celebrated all over the world.
Obviously, but maybe nowhere
more than in Key West, Florida,
where he lived in the
twenties and thirties.
For 40 years, the community has held
a huge Ernest Hemingway
look-alike competition.
More than a hundred guys
from all over the country,
come down to vie for the title.
For this year's winner,
the victory was extra special.
He won two decades after
his late father-in-law won.
Which is awesome.
Let's say hi to the 2021 Ernest
Hemingway look-alike winner,
Zach, dialing in from Douglas, Georgia.
Where he watches us on WALB 10 at three.
(Kelly claps)
(audience applauding)
Whats up, Zach.
- How are you?
How are you Kelly?
- I'm so good.
I like Sloppy Joe's too.
I see your shirt.
The competition is a big
deal in your family, right?
- Yes, it is.
My father-in-law won in
2000 and it's very special.
We slipped down and surprised him
in his second year of competing in '98
and all had a big time.
And even after he won,
we decided we would continue to go back
and support other Papas or
wannabes as we call them,
trying to be a Papa and
support the Look-Alike Society
and the good things that they try to do.
It's just been a lot of fun going back,
and we have a big time
every year down there.
- I love it.
(audience applauding)
I could hear you talk all day long.
I love your accent.
Oh my goodness.
So what was it like to
take the title this year?
That must have been pretty cool.
- It was really a shock.
You know, after seeing
a lot of competitions,
I know it's not a sprint, it's a marathon.
You normally have several
years of competing,
and hoping that you've proved your.
- Lookalike-ness?
(Kelly laughs)
- Your tenacity to be a Papa.
I competed my first year in 2019,
and didn't have it last year
because of the pandemic.
This year we went back down
and you know,
was just thinking, I'd be lucky again.
Maybe if I could make
it back to the finals
on Saturday night.
Was really shocked when I
made it to the final five
and was really shocked
when I made it through the three way tie
for the Papa.
And it's just overwhelming
and just really,
really, really still enjoying the ride.
- Oh, that's so Cool!
And I love that.
It's like a family tradition
now for your family.
Thank you so much, Zach.
And congratulations.
I'm liking your posts right now.
(bell dings)
(audience applauding)
And that's not all, man.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you.
So they're gonna be using
their G2 jelling pen
to write you a check for a $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Great! Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, man.